there was a scene where i got shot in
the head by seth rogen there were some
angles where they were shooting wides
and stuff but i just knew
for a fact i'm not in the shot
we made you lay there all day right
yeah yeah so i like that this
is considered a nice thing i did for you
so there was a time like an hour to end
a couple of setups i just stood up and i
go i'm not laying there anymore yeah
there was a metal plate in my head
because they had to put an explosive on
the other side of the metal plate
they're laying on the metal yeah so when
they're shooting me right there's an
explosive right so now i'm laying
not only there's sticky blood but
there's a metal plate into my brain can
i tell you something that's like
terrible about maybe the early stages of
my career go ahead there is nothing i
would have found funnier than to make
you lay in blood all day off camera
telling you you're on camera